JESSE WATTERS, DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
SATURDAY WAS THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER.
HERE'S A CLIP.
>> IT IS A TRASH FIRE.
>> Greg: WE COULD STOP THERE.
EVERYTHING WENT AS PLANNED.
THE COMEDIAN, ON DILUTED LEFTIST
PLUCKED FROM DAILY SHOW ASSEMBLY
LINE.
UNLOADED ON THE WHITE HOUSE.
LIKE A TORTOISE ON CRUTCHES, YOU
COULD SEE THE JOKES LIMPING
TOWARD YOU.
THE DINNER IS OLD NEWS, AN OF
SELF CONGRATULATIONS, SELFIES,
PREDICTABLE BARBS.
>> I HAVE TO SAY I AM A LITTLE
STARSTRUCK.
I LOVE YOU AS AUNT LYDIA IN THE
HANDMAID'S TALE.
I ACTUALLY REALLY LIKE SARAH.
I THINK SHE IS VERY RESOURCEFUL.
LIKE SHE BURNS FACTS AND USES
THE ASH TO CREATE A PERFECT
SMOKY EYE.
MAYBE SHE IS BORN WITH IT.
MAYBE IT'S LIES.
PROBABLY LIVES.
I AM NEVER SURE WHAT TO CALL
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS.
IS IT SARAH SANDERS?
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS?
WHAT IS UNCLE TOM BUT FOR WHITE
WOMEN WHO DISAPPOINT OTHER WHITE
WOMEN?
>> Greg: WOLF REMINDS US YOU
CAN SMEAR WOMEN AS LONG AS YOU
ON THE RIGHT.
THE MEDIA CALLS IT A ROAST.
IF  IF YOU DID IT COME IT WOULDB
IF  IF YOU DID IT COME IT WOULDE
CALLED MISOGYNY.
PROGRESSIVES PLAY BY DIFFERENT
RULES.
TAKE JOY REID.
WHATEVER SHE WRITES WILL BE
EXCUSED.
BEING ON THE LEFT EXCUSES
EVERYTHING.
YOU CAN DRIVE GIRLS INTO THE
DRINK OR RUN THE CLAN AND STILL
SIT IN THE SENATE AS LONG AS
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT.
THE COMMENTS DEFENDERS WILL SAY
CIAMPA SAID BAD THINGS ABOUT
WOMEN TOO.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
HE SAID BAD THINGS ABOUT
EVERYONE.
BUT IF HE WASN'T PRESIDENT AND
MARCO RUBIO WAS, DO YOU THINK
MICHELLE WOULD BE ANY NICER TO
RUBIO?
HE IS PRO-LIFE.
SHE IS THIS.
>> MIKE PENCE IS ANTICHOICE.
HE THINKS ABORTION IS MURDER.
BUT DON'T KNOCK IT UNTIL WE'VE
TRIED IT.
>> Greg: MAYBE THAT'S WHAT
BRIAN SELTZER CONSIDERS BRAVE
MATERIAL.
YEAH, CIAMPA SAID BAD THINGS BUT
HE CRUSHED ISIS AND -- I WILL
TAKE THE TRAY OFF EVEN IF I HAVE
TO LISTEN TO BAD JOKES.
KIMBERLY, I GO TO YOU.
I BELIEVE YOU FEEL STRONGLY.
>> YOU ARE MONITORING ME ALL
WEEKEND.
>> Greg: I WAS OUTSIDE YOUR
HOUSE.
SO I HAVE TO TELL YOU.
I FELT THIS WAS SO MEAN-SPIRITED
THAT IT WASN'T ANYTHING THAT WAS
COMEDIC.
THERE WAS NOTHING TO BE GAINED
FOR HER SAYING THESE TYPE OF
THINGS THAT WERE DIRECTLY
TARGETED.
I THINK OF THE MAJORITY OF WHAT
SHE HAD TO SAY -- THIS ISN'T
ADVANCING THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
THIS IS PROFFERING CRUELTY.
IF YOU ARE SITTING IN A CHAIR
LIKE THAT TO LISTEN TO THAT, AND
EVERYBODY, I GUESS SOME PEOPLE
LAUGHED BUT TO GO ON IN THIS
WAY, I THOUGHT IT WAS ABSOLUTELY
TERRIBLE.
WE WERE ALL INVITED.
WE DIDN'T GO.
YOU WENT.
I THINK YOU WERE THE ONLY ONE OF
THE FIVE OF US.
JUAN WILL SAY WITH HIS PERSONAL
EXPENSE WAS THERE AND LISTENING.
SOMETIMES IT'S DIFFERENT.
AT HOME, AND WE WATCHED IT SO
MANY TIMES MY FELT SO SAD FOR
HER.
SARAH CONDUCTED HERSELF
BEAUTIFULLY AND HANDLED HERSELF
WELL.
TO SIT THERE AND LISTEN, SO
MEAN-SPIRITED, BULLYING.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
I WOULDN'T LIKE IT IF SHE SAID
THAT ABOUT A MAN, A WOMAN, A
CHILD.
WHAT DID SARAH SANDERS EVER DO
TO HURT TO DESERVE THOSE
PERSONAL ATTACKS ON THAT LEVEL
OF VITRIOL?
SHE SHOULD BE HORRIBLE ABOUT
HERSELF WHEN SHE GOES TO BED AND
WHEN SHE WAKES UP IN THE
MORNING, MICHELLE WOLF.
NOTHING IT WAS -- NOTHING OF IT
WAS FUNNY WHATSOEVER.
>> Greg: THEY WOULD RESPOND
THAT BECAUSE TRUMP WASN'T THERE,
SHE BECOMES THE TARGET.
SHE IS THE PROXY.
NUMBER TWO, TRUMP HAS SAID
THINGS ABOUT PEOPLE'S FACES
TWICE.
>> Dana: AND SOME PEOPLE
LAUGHED.
ACROSS THE BOARD, I DON'T GET
GOOD OR FUNNY.
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT
THIS, IF YOU WANT TO GO THE
PRESIDENT WENT TO THE GRIDIRON
DINNER AND IT WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST THAT HE'S ATTENDED.
HE BROUGHT THE HOUSE DOWN.
HE WAS VERY FUNNY.
HIS SPEECH WAS GREAT.
NANCY PELOSI WAS ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS.
I THINK THAT NIGHT, AND THEN TOM
COTTON.
USUALLY IF YOU HAVE AN ELECTED
LEADER WHO HAS -- IT'S NOT EASY
TO GIVE A SPEECH LIKE THAT.
THEY HAVE TO PRACTICE.
IT COSTS A LOT BECAUSE I USUALLY
FARM IT OUT TO SOME A GREAT
SPEECHWRITER.
I DON'T PICK WASHINGTON, D.C.,
NEEDS TO BRING IN ANYONE FROM
THE OUTSIDE TO DO THIS TYPES OF
THINGS.
THE GRIDIRON DINNER HAS NEVER
DONE IT.
IT'S ALWAYS FANTASTIC.
THE LINE THEY HAVE, THE GRIDIRON
SINGES BUT IT NEVER BURNS.
I HOPE THAT'S THE LAST OF THE
SOUND BITES I HAVE TO HEAR.
HER VOICE IS REALLY, IT REALLY
GETS TO ME.
CRAIG FERGUSON WAS ONE OF THE
ONLY COMEDIANS THERE THAT I
THOUGHT WAS SO GENTLE.
HE BASICALLY MADE FUN OF HIMSELF
THE ENTIRE TIME, ANTICOMPLEMENT
TO ME.
SO I REMEMBER THAT.
SHE TALKS ABOUT THE ABORTION
JOKE.
ONE THING YOU COULD SAY IN
RESPONSE, AT LEAST SHE CALLED IN
A BABY.
>> Greg: THAT WAS THE BIGGEST
FLAW.
>> Dana: OH, SO NOW YOU THINK
IT'S A BABY.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE BACK TO THE
CONGRESS.
>> Greg: THAT WAS A BIG FLAW
AND IT UNDERMINED HER JOKE.
OBAMA GIVES GREAT SPEECHES.
THEY DIDN'T NEED A COMEDIAN.
>> Dana: THE ELECTED LEADERS
WHO GIVE FUNNY SPEECHES, NOT
EVEN ELECTED LEADERS.
LAURA BUSH, WHEN SHE DID IT ONE
YEAR AT THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER, IT WAS
HILARIOUS.
WHEN SHE CALLED HERSELF A
"DESPERATE HOUSEWIVES."
EVERYBODY GOT IT.
YOU DON'T NEED TO BRING IN SOME
OF THE FROM THE OUTSIDE.
>> Kimberly: I AGREE WITH YOU,
DANA.
WHEN OBAMA SPOKE, HE WAS FUNNY,
ENTERTAINING.
PEOPLE WOULD GO.
NO ONE WANTS TO LISTEN TO THIS
NONSENSE.
>> Greg: NOT A ROUSING
SUCCESS.
>> Jesse: ROSEANNE BARR SAID
THE FIRST RULE OF COMEDY, YOU
DON'T TARGET SOMEONE IN THE
AUDIENCE WAS MORE FAMOUS THAN
YOU ARE.
YOU WILL LOSE THE ENTIRE CROWD.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
YOU BOOK A C LIST COMEDIAN TO
MAKE FUN OF THE A-LISTERS.
LOOK WHO THEY HAVE HAD.
SISLEY STRONG, LARRY WILMORE,
MICHELLE WOLF, HASSAN MENAGE.
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF THESE
PEOPLE.
>> Greg: THEY ARE ALL THE
DAILY SHOW.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE NOT FAMOUS
COMEDIANS.
DURING OBAMA, THEY HAD CONAN,
JIMMY KIMMEL, SETH MEYERS, JAY
LENO.
UNDER BUSH, COLBERT, JAY LENO,
DREW CAROL.
>> Dana: THEY SAY THAT COLBERT
ENDED UP WITH THE PRIME TIME
LATE SHOW BECAUSE OF THE
PERFORMANCE.
>> Jesse: IN THAT CASE, I
BLAME THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER
ASSOCIATION FOR HIM BUT THE
DELIVERY WAS TERRIBLE IN THIS,
AVERAGE MATERIAL.
THE VOICE WAS NOT GOOD.
I'M GLAD YOU SET IT AND I DIDN'T
HAVE TO SAY IT FIRST.
BUT THE POINT IS, I BLAME THE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS'
DINNER ASSOCIATION FOR THIS.
THEY KNEW WHAT THEY WERE GETTING
INTO WHEN THEY BOOKED THIS
PERSON.
BUT THIS IS WHO THE LEFT IS.
THEY HAVE BEEN SMEARING AND
HURTING CONSERVATIVES AND
TRAFFICKING IN THIS KIND OF
HATEFUL, UNFUNNY STUFF FOR THE
LAST YEAR.
ON THE SHOW WE'VE HAD MONTAGES
OF THE STUFF FROM CHELSEA
HANDLER GOING AFTER MELANIA.
THE ASSASSINATION JOKES WITH
KATHY GRIFFIN.
JOHNNY DEPP.
YOU HAD CHRIS MATTHEW SAY
HORRIBLE THINGS.
WHAT THEY SAY ON "MORNING JOE."
SWEAR WORDS ON CNN.
IT'S BEEN DESPICABLE.
NO ONE HAS EVER CONDEMNED IT,
AND HERE'S THE REASONS WHY THEY
CONDEMNED IT THIS TIME.
IT WAS DONE IN THEIR ROOM AT
THEIR DINNER BY A COMEDIAN WHO
THEY HIRED, AND IT WAS DONE TO
THE PERSON'S FACE.
ALL THE OTHER HATEFUL STUFF WAS
ON TWITTER.
IT WAS ON SOMEONE ELSE'S SHOW.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY.
THE REASON THEY HAD TO CONDEMN
THIS COMEDIAN NOW IS BECAUSE IT
WAS A P.R. PROBLEM FOR THEM.
THEY WERE ONLY DOING IT FOR THAT
REASON AND THAT REASON ALONE.
>> Greg: JUAN, TO THAT POINT,
DO YOU THINK THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS ASSOCIATION WAS
COWARDLY FOR DISTANCING
THEMSELVES?
I DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE.
THEY MADE THE DECISION TO HAVE
HER THERE.
THEY SHOULD HAVE SUPPORTED HER
EYE THINK.
>> Juan: I THINK THEY MUST BE
REACTING TO SOME BACKLASH THEY
RECEIVED.
I THINK THE BACKLASH IN MY MIND
TO SOMEONE WHO WAS THERE, THERE
WAS NO ONE WALKING OUT, BY THE
WAY.
YOU HAD SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS
SITTING ON THE STAGE.
I BELIEVE SHE WAS TWO PEOPLE
REMOVED FROM THE LECTERN.
SHE IS SITTING THERE, AND EVEN
THE TV CAMERAS THEN ENLARGED THE
PERSPECTIVE SO YOU COULD SEE
SANDERS REACTING TO MISS WOLF.
THE PROBLEM WAS IT JUST FELT
UNFAIR TO HER.
I THOUGHT -- I SAW SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS AND I SAID I
THINK YOU HAVE A GREAT SENSE OF
HUMOR BECAUSE IN THE MOMENT YOU
WERE WORRIED SHE WAS GOING TO
BURST INTO TEARS OR STAND UP AND
WALK OUT AND THERE WOULD BE A
WHOLE DEAL ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS ASSOCIATION
WANTED THEIR EVENT.
WHERE I DISAGREE WITH YOU GUYS,
SHE WAS HILARIOUS.
I THINK SHE WAS GENIUS FUNNY.
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
SHE WAS PICKING ON THE PRESS A
LOT.
SHE WAS PICKING ON DEMOCRATS.
SHE SAID ABOUT THE IDEA THAT
FRANKEN IS GONE, SHE SAID TED
KENNEDY PROBABLY SAID HEY, I
MURDERED A GIRL, THAT KIND OF
THING.
>> Greg: THAT WAS A GOOD JOKE.
>> Juan: LIES HERE WITH YOU
GUYS, YOU TALK ABOUT LIBERAL
INTOLERANCE FOR A VARIETY OF
VOICES AND SPEECH.
HERE'S A VARIETY OF COLOR HERE'S
A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE.
SHE WENT AFTER AND PROBABLY HER
MOST TELLING THING WAS SHE SAID
YOU KNOW, YOU GUYS IN THE PRESS,
YOU CREATED THIS MONSTER.
AND NOW YOU ARE MAKING BOOKS,
PODCASTS, TV SHOWS, MAKING
MONEY.
BUT ALL YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IS TRUMP AND RUSSIA.
ANOTHER GOOD PART WAS WHEN SHE
WENT AFTER WHITE WOMEN.
I'VE NEVER HEARD ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
SHE SAID YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON NOT ONLY WITH SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS BUT YOU THINK
ABOUT KELLYANNE CONWAY.
YOU THINK ABOUT IVANKA.
EVERYBODY SAYS WOMEN'S ISSUES
ARE GOING TO BE AT THE
FOREFRONT.
SHE SAID YOU GUYS HAD
DISAPPOINTED WHITE WOMEN AND SHE
CALLED THEM UNCLE TOMS IN TERMS
OF WHITE WOMEN.
EVERYBODY, WHERE I WAS SAYING,
-- SITTING, PEOPLE WERE
LAUGHING.
>> Jesse: I WATCH THE WHOLE
THING ON C-SPAN.
SHE LOST THE CROWD EARLY AND SHE
BOMBED.
THERE'S SO MUCH GOOD MATERIAL
ABOUT THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE FROM
JIM ACOSTA TO TWITTER TO THE
RUSSIANS TO PELOSI AND
CHUCK SCHUMER.
IT IS SO EASY TO MAKE, EVEN
CLEAN JOKES, THE MAJORITY OF THE
STUFF WAS VERY DIRTY.
I CAN HANDLE DIRTY JOKES AND
EVERYBODY THERE CAN HANDLE DIRTY
JOKES.
I THINK IT TAKES MORE TALENT TO
BE CLEAN.
ALMOST EVERYTHING IS FILTHY.
YOU CAN BE MEAN BUT THE JOKES
HAVE TO LAND.
>> Kimberly: DO YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT IS, JESSE SAYING HE CAN DO
IT.
WANTING GREG TO DO IT.
>> Greg: DONALD TRUMP HAD A
SUGGESTION HOW TO MAKE IT BETTER
AND IT WAS:
THE SO-CALLED COMEDIAN REALLY
"BOMBED."
@GregGutfeld SHOULD HOST NEXT
YEAR!
SO I AM SAYING YES.
LET'S DO A COUNTER DINNER.
MAYBE FOR POLICE WIDOWS, THE